well the first one was horrible so let's
review this I mean why not Weegee origin
evil so eg origin of evil is the sequel
to the shitty Ouija movie it's actually
a prequel to the Ouija movie this takes
place in the 1960s in Los Angeles which
I was pretty pumped for because I like
old-school Los Angeles in the end it
doesn't actually mean anything because
it takes place in the 60s yes but
nothing in this movie actually was
specifically a Los Angeles thing it
could have taken place in the 60s in
Mobile Alabama wouldn't have made the
movie any different whatsoever so it
takes place in the 1960s on earth in
America and this is family with good
intentions they're scamming people to
give them closure about loved ones who
have died but in the end like all of
these they're scams I didn't think it a
Ouija board and then bad things start
happening and then we have our haunting
/ possession ghost movie well that's
quite a bit better than the first one no
to be honest with you about that
granted saying a sequel to the original
Ouija movie is better is no feat
whatsoever I'm just I'm actually saying
I enjoyed Ouija origin of evil as a
movie crazy first of all the actors in
the movie did a good job I mean from the
hottest mom ever seriously I
Wow but she did a good job at bringing
hearts and trying to keep this family
afloat when they're going through
financial troubles then the older
daughter did a great job in her role of
being the rebellious teen yes but she's
not the problem problem comes from the
little girl not her acting I thought she
was great she is she's a creep which is
great because you first seared your look
oh you're cute kid then later on in the
movies just all evil you're like get out
of my house demon child that's a lot to
put on that girl there's a lot resting
on this little girl's shoulders to
ultimately beat Damien from The Omen for
this one and she did a good job what any
scene is happening and she's in the room
after you know the ghost stuff starts
going down just look at her and you're
like let's go somewhere else she's
making me uneasy and the effectiveness
of the storytelling completely worked to
see this is a movie about a family and
their struggles that happens to have a
haunting happen in it it's not just
ghost [ __ ] thrown at your face for the
sake of ghosts [ __ ] right - there are a
couple of jump scares in here but at
this point I feel like every haunting
movie has them but what this movie does
have it makes up for it in the sense
that I I feel like telling you about
this is spoiling it for you
then again I don't feel like anyone's
going to watch this movie so I feel like
I'm spoiling it for about six of you so
here we go not going to tell you when it
happens at all I'm saying throughout the
movie there are parts where a scene is
happening in the background there is a
spiritual shadow there is an essence
there's a black mass person and it's
awesome because it's not framed up to
look like it's gonna be obvious usually
a horror movie has someone like this and
it's clearly something's gonna happen
over there obviously just in the way
it's framed not this one it's scenes
happening and you're like oh that's it
that was a shadow oh my god and not
everyone's gonna see it happens with for
the people who do notice it it's an
easter egg makes the movie a little more
fun speaking of easter eggs this movie
has real changes that's just the
projection is did me man you remember in
Fight Club Tyler Durden talked about
cigarette burns and a little real change
dot that happens at the corner of the
screen you don't see that much anymore
because everything's digital and they
don't have real changes it's very the
movie a bit more fun I just like it when
a movie can have fun if there's ever a
genre to do something like that's gotta
be the horror genre so all that
effectiveness aside the flaws come from
the fact that the movie does drag on in
parts I found myself yawning about it a
little over halfway through the movie
and that's not just me wishing for more
scary [ __ ] to happen though I could have
gone for that a family dynamic alone
wasn't always enough to drive the plot
forward it works for a big chunk of it
not a point you just want things to get
going
and it wasn't always going the movie
easily could have been about 10 to 15
minutes shorter it really could if it
ended like three times but it doesn't
take away from the fact that I walked
out of this movie going yeah
alright so props to this I expect it to
murder this thing I expect you to get on
camera be like alright guys let's get to
work but I will definitely say it's
worth watching no alcohol required right
guys so we g2 have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
horror movie sequel ever whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know no aliens doesn't count
alien is a horror movie aliens is not
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]